Wednesday Adams in the MCU keep watching
to see how one fan brought that Vision
to life plus a look back at Jenna
Ortega's previous MCU appearance which
was also her film debut as the MCU
continues to expand it'll have to dig
deep into Marvel Comics Reservoir to
tell new stories white tiger is one of
the many lesser-known superheroes that
have long been cult favorites also known
as Eva Ayala white Tiger's superhuman
fighting skills and razor sharp claws
puts her on equal footing with some of
Marvel's finest never bring a knife to a
sword fight
unless it's concealed with unconfirmed
and Anonymous rumors of Wednesday star
Jenna Ortega possibly joining the mcu's
Daredevil franchise as the character
fans of the actress are Imagining the
exciting possibilities however casting
details for the series Daredevil born
again have yet to be fully revealed
which means her participation in the
upcoming show remains intriguing gossip
at best still this news has inspired one
artist who reimagined existing
illustrations of white tiger with the
actresses likeness added to stunning
Effect one fan on Instagram known as our
Affinity has created two images of
Ortega in a rendition of the superheroes
costume the first design features the
actress out of her mask staring forward
at the viewer and the second places
white Tiger's helmet over her face both
pictures generated praise from
commenters with one sharing good casting
maybe that could happen in Daredevil
born again another fan had a different
opinion on who they wished or take it to
play a character from another Cinematic
Universe entire early she'd be a better
Jessica Cruz AKA Green Lantern white
tiger appeared in animated form in the
Disney XD Series Ultimate Spider-Man
which also has some wondering if the
hero would even fit well in a daredevil
property one fan posted on Reddit I love
white tiger I've only seen her in the
Ultimate Spider-Man show but I don't
think her character would fit as well in
a daredevil show than it would in a
black panther or Iron Fist series if our
affinity's art is anything to go by
Jenna Ortega is a great choice for the
part white tiger debuted in 1975 with
the character making his first
appearance in Marvel's deadly hands of
kung fu number 19. the moniker of white
tiger was initially taken on by Hector
Ayala who used the power of the Jade
tiger amulets to transform into the hero
the amulets afforded Ayala the strength
dexterity and skills of a powerful
martial artist making him a true force
to be reckoned with considered to be
Marvel's first Latino superhero the
first iteration of the white tiger
brushed shoulders with other New York
City Heroes including Spider-Man and
Daredevil the moniker of the white tiger
was passed down for several Generations
eventually landing on Avion Hector's
younger sister Ava also happens to be
the aunt of Angela Del Toro another
Marvel heroine who possesses the powers
of the white tiger Ava inherits the Jay
tiger amulet from her brother and
decides to hone her powers by joining
The Avengers Academy having Jenna Ortega
step into the role of the white tiger
would certainly be interesting
especially as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe continues to focus on more
diverse stories and characters though it
remains to be seen if Ortega will join
Daredevil born again she's already
joined the MCU kinda she had a small
role as the vice president's daughter in
2013's Iron Man 3. her first appearance
on the big screen
foreign
[Music]